i'm starting with beauty shots of
edinburgh the capital of scotland we're
looking down the city's royal mile here
a favorite with visitors in one of the
city's busiest streets edinburgh
features neoclassical architecture it's
also the home to arthur's seat that's
king arthur to you tom yes it is it's
it's got a little touristy feel to it do
you want to you know change it from the
touristy ticky tacky into something
different is there a sturgeon plan to
make it oh edinburgh hayden is a
fantastic international city and you
know we're heading into festival season
when edinburgh will come alive with the
edinburgh festivals
come on you just you have this
exactly edible is the royal mile here
come on anybody watching if you haven't
visited edinburgh get to edinburgh for
the international festival you will love
it too let's move on
featured in tom game of thrones dune
castle is located in central scotland it
was the set for winterfell on the pilot
episode of game of thrones no wonder
this whole thing was picked up the 13th
century castle also used though in monty
python and the holy grail a far more
important fact i might add archers
are castles falling apart like in france
no we've got a fantastic
preservation
we invest in historic buildings historic
scotland the national trust for scotland
we take great pride in our historic
buildings
we'll just uh move on to the final photo
it's a little bit different but also
similar in the uk the kensington palace
shared baby photographs of prince george
and princess charlotte on twitter
wearing scottish blue socks
george turns two later this month kate
middleton the duchess of cambridge took
the pictures herself and can i just say
it's all downhill from there tom is home
i also have one not quite as good of a
photographer that's amazing she needs to
prepare herself for years of teasing i
would say that kate middleton got the
lighting better than than your parents
did on that one